creo que ha sido la coherencia con su
campaña y la coherencia con la cual
llega el poder y hay una propuesta y de
fondo que tendría que ser analizado
porque la propuesta de un estado
socialista democrático que significa eso
bueno yo interpretó que eso significa
que gobernará con una participación
equitativa ciudadana eso es lo que yo
interpreto verdad y en lo que él llama
socialismo democrático
pero puede ser que tenga otros
contenidos aunque toda su
proceso
antes de la toma de posesión ha sido
debates con todos los movimientos
sociales del país con los movimientos
indígenas con los movimientos sindicales
con los movimientos campesinos bueno
alrededor creo que de 700 propuestas
salen de estos movimientos entonces aquí
digamos es como una como su propuesta
verdad compuesta del plan de gobierno es
considero lo importante ahora y creo que
el tema de la corrupción que es un tema
de honduras escandaloso pero que también
es un tema del área centroamericana beta
no todos los países pero sí sí digamos
hemos compartido nos dura lo que fue la
iniciativa de la masa y ahora la
presidenta zelaya ya hizo las primeras
gestiones para que se instale en el país
lo que ella más sí sí que sería el
organismo que trabajaría digamos contra
la impunidad de la corrupción porque si
ha sido escandaloso y creo que los datos
que presenta pues lógicamente
es un país en el iam en bancarrota pero
yo creo que teníamos digamos las
posibilidades o sea nosotros como país
nos hemos levantado de muchas
catástrofes no solamente políticas sino
también políticas y catástrofes fuertes
como fue el mitch verdad como fue toyota
o sea somos un país con mucha
vulnerabilidad ambiental social política
y
lógicamente encontramos digamos en estos
procesos participativos equitativos que
son los negaron durante 12 años y
caminos y vías para poder salir y yo
tengo confianza no solamente en la
presidenta sino también confianza en
nosotros digamos yo trabajo en la
universidad la universidad por un papel
importante digamos en este país a nivel
de propuestas lo que sucede que en estos
12 años ninguna de las propuestas
elaboradas por la universidad por
técnicos han sido escuchadas o sean
hemos tenido esa
y un tema importante que es el de
energía eléctrica que también es un tema
mundial creo yo verdad que tiene que ver
con todo el tema ambiental que es un
tema central a nivel universal y el tema
de migración que como decía el tema de
migración es un efecto de las
desigualdades sociales y de género que
en mi país existe entonces aquí digamos
necesitamos
una vuelta a lo que serían los estados
de bienestar espero que cuando ella
llama de este estado socialista también
estamos hablando de un estado de
bienestar con políticas universales en
salud en educación en vivienda porque el
modelo neoliberal digamos lo que nos ha
generado es una profundización digamos
de la pobreza y principalmente de la
pobreza de las mujeres entonces
creo yo que tiene que ver digamos un
cambio de modelo un cambio de modelo de
desarrollo o sea este modelo que es un
modelo extractivista que es un modelo de
achicamiento de estado es un modelo que
lógicamente no ha funcionado no
solamente en honduras sino en todo el
área centroamericana porque ha ido más
crecimiento de pobreza entonces para mí
sería como cómo plantear digamos lo que
sería una un nuevo consenso social
verdad para un cambio de modelo y que
tenga que ver también con todos estos
factores
internacionales y regionales yo creo que
la integración de la región es muy
importante porque este problema sólo lo
tenemos en toda la región
centroamericana entonces creo que como
región tenemos que buscar también
salidas porque cultura es un país
pequeño pero si integramos la región
lógicamente podemos encontrar salidas
más acertadas creo yo